[Musica]
benvenuto il nuovo episodio delle ciò
con karim usa a godzilla cosa si può
dire di questa saga ma in realtà un
sacco di roma è uno squarcio della
cultura giapponese
ma sono anche degli stuntman con dei
costumi da mostro hanno creato mostre
combattimenti che sono entrati nella
storia del cinema ma hanno creato anche
dei momenti parecchio imbarazzanti
insomma si possono dire una marea di
cose sulla saga di godzilla
ma c'è una cosa in particolare che mi ha
sempre stupito leggendola su internet e
cioè che c'è un sacco di gente e l'ho
vista con i miei occhi che non ha la
minima idea che esistano più di due film
di godzilla al di fuori di quelli
americani o magari qualcuno ne è venuto
a conoscenza ma non ha approfondito più
di tanto e quindi pensa che ce ne siano
altri due o tre giapponesi o son
contento guarda voi non avete idea
e siccome l'anno scorso in giappone
hanno fatto uscire dopo anni di silenzio
un nuovo godzilla ufficiale chiamato
sheen godzilla che purtroppo non ho
ancora visto anche perché lasciando da
parte le trasposizioni americane come
godzilla e godzilla i film della saga
giapponese solo un po più difficili da
trovare
certo se te li scarichi da internet li
trovi all'istante ma se uno se li
volesse comprare dal primo all'ultimo
inizierebbe a fare leggermente più
fatica perché alcuni sono arrivati in
italia altri no alcuni sono arrivati in
dvd altri no e quindi devi andati a
cercare le videocassette giapponesi
americane o magari devi andare su ebay o
su qualche sito di importazione magari
su amazon c'è qualche cofanetto o magari
se uno non vuole prendersi gli 1x1
riuscire a trovare un rivenditore
tedesco che era uno strano cofanetto
misterioso questo è uno dei pochi
cofanetti belliche sono riuscito a
trovare di godzilla ma non ci sono tutti
ce ne sono più o meno la metà gli altri
me li sono dovuti comprare in dvd
singoli tralasciando la grandissima
figata che è la confezione aperta dentro
ci sono undici film non in ordine
cronologico quindi sono undici film
sparpagliati nei 28 e tutti in lingua
tedesca ma ringraziando iddio ci sono
anche c'è anche la lingua giapponese i
sottotitoli
e dentro c'è anche un bellissimo
libretto pieno di fotografie
informazioni in tedesco e come vedete
sembra la locandina di un manifesto
nazista quindi oggi io voglio
riassumerli tutti e 28 i film delle tre
ere giapponesi dei film di godzilla in
pochissime parole e tra l'altro siccome
ci sono talmente tante trasposizioni in
italiano e in inglese solo i sottotitoli
inglese col doppiaggio in inglese con
doppiaggio giapponese
ho deciso che prenderò i riferimenti
americani fatevi un tè caldo prendetevi
lo snack e portiamo godzilla una
creatura gigantesca appare al largo
delle coste giapponesi e distrugge tutto
ciò che si trova davanti la gente del
posto la chiama gojira ma con un'arma
chiamata oxygen destroyer che distrugge
gli atomi di ossigeno degli organismi
cosa riescono ad uccidere godzilla ea
salvare il mondo e siamo solo all'inizio
godzilla rise again per la prima volta a
godzilla combatte con un altro mostro
angoli russo o angela si in base alla
versione che stai guardando rischiando
di distruggere osaka godzilla sconfigge
angus ma viene sotterrato da una
montagna di ghiaccio grazie
all'intervento dei militari king kong
versus godzilla come nelle migliori
collaudi youtube decidono di far
scontrare due titani del cinema in kong
e godzilla lottano come due bambini a
cui hanno dato una sola merendina in
finale lo considero un pareggio nella
versione americana il montaggio fa
vincere king kong nella versione
giapponese godzilla è ancora vivo quindi
mostra versus godzilla qui si inizia ad
andare sul particolare viene ritrovato
un nuovo gigante sulle coste appartiene
a vo tra una creatura venerata dalla
popolazione locale per riprendersi
l'uovo arrivano due piccolissime donne
gemelle queste sorelle kessler
nipponiche non fanno in tempo ad andare
via che si risveglia godzilla quindi per
salvare tutti le gemelle evoca lo mostra
per menare godzilla però purtroppo muore
letteralmente di fatica ma l'uovo si
schiude facendo uscire due larve giganti
che intrappolano godzilla e lo fanno
cadere in mare piccolissima
particolarità questo film in italiano è
chiamato nel favoloso impero dei mostri
ecco spiegato il perché io utilizzi la
versione dei nomi in inglese di dora
defluire baby boxster una principessa
viene posseduta dallo spirito di un
abitante di marte che le predice
l'arrivo di una creatura dallo spazio
che distruggerà la terra wow
lei è di d'ora ma purtroppo godzilla
impegnato a menarsi corro da una
creatura alata allora per convincerlo
ritornano le sorelle kessler con mostra
in forma larvale i tre mostri uniscono
le loro forze per battere good ora
facendolo tornare nello spazio invasion
of di astro monster viene scoperto un
nuovo pianeta chiamato pianeta hicks
cioè qui la fantasia sta volando a dei
livelli altissimi
gli alieni di questo pianeta però sono
sotto attacco da parte di un mostro ed
ora di nuovo per salvare il pianeta
gli umani manda rossi a godzilla che
road han a fare un carico nei sughi
d'ora ma colpo di scena era tutto un
barbatrucco degli allievi per attaccare
la terra con tutti e tre i mostri ma
alla fine la terra riprende il controllo
di godzilla e rodano riuscendo a
sconfiggere gli dora godzilla versus i
monster un gruppo di ragazzi finisce su
un'isola in cui c'è una setta segreta
che possiede un'aragosta gigante come
animale domestico e bira i ragazzi per
riuscire a scappare risvegliano godzilla
che distrugge tutto e tutti godzilla
prima lotta contro i bira poi viene
attaccato da un uccello gigante di nome
dai condurrà voglio dire a chi non è mai
capitata una roba del genere mentre
l'isola sta per esplodere mostra salva
tutti gli abitanti sanno godzilla mamma
mia ma che incubo che sei
lui è un cucciolo di godzilla chiamato
di milla che viene trovato su un'isola
piena di effetti enormi godzilla uccide
tutti i mostri e inizia a fare da mamma
al disastro della natura cercando di
insegnargli le basi della sopravvivenza
e il tutto finisce con loro congelati
ok destroy all monsters questa è la
royal rumble briefing
sulla terra sono riusciti a catturare
una marea di mostri diversi godzilla
mostra rodan angus goro sounds paragon
ma da como ga varun eppure il piccolo
schifo di milla ma degli alieni li
dividono e li sparpagliano in tutti i
paesi facendogli fare casino alcuni
astronauti riescono a distruggere le
basi aliena e a calmare i mostri che
potrebbe mai finire così il film è ovvio
che no e infatti arriva pure grid ora di
nuovo a rompere le balle
così tutti i mostri si uniscono per
prenderlo a calci nel culo e
sconfiggerlo ed ora per favore
lascia perdere così lassry vincere
[Musica]
un bambino viene preso di mira dai bulli
il cui capo si chiama gabar a quando va
a dormire sonia di essere su un isola a
fare amicizia con mi villa sempre più
brutto tra l'altro porca [ __ ] ma anche
nei mille perseguitato da un mostro
bullo di nome gabbana pure quello
cazzo a volte le coincidenze del mondo
mimina sconfigge kabara e dalla forza al
bambino di sconfiggere il bullo siamo
passati da un mostro che distrugge la
città a mega risse contro mostri alieni
a firma con la trama di karate kid
sono senza parole e non siamo neanche a
metà
così la versus ed ora di questo non c'è
moltissimo da dire un meteorite fa
cadere sulla terra un mostro alieno che
si nutre di inquinamento chiamato ed ora
così la c combattere e vincere fine
nulla di che a parte la famosa scena in
cui il godzilla vola all'indietro
sparando il suo oggetto atomico dalla
bocca come se fosse un missile terra
aria ma niente di che godzilla o monster
island degli alieni
mamma mia che novità arrivano sulla
terra facendo finta di essere umani
costruendo una barca ma il tutto è una
copertura in realtà vogliono distruggere
l'umanità comandando i loro due mostri
gagan un nuovo mostro superfigo devo
dire con delle lame a uncino al posto
delle mani e un occhio rosso lasen tipo
sign on e poi con il secondo mostro e
chi sarà mai
maggie d'ora oggi sei mancato bentornato
godzilla accompagnato nuovamente dong
hui rus fa tornare nello spazio i due
nemici godzilla versus belga l'on
i terrestri continuano a fare il test
nucleari sotto terra disturbando una
civiltà che vive proprio sotto terra
questi all'eu piani così vengono
chiamati siccome gli han disturbato il
sonno rilasciano la loro creatura mega
l'on
una specie di scarabeo gli umani però
hanno un asso nella manica jet jaguar un
bellissimo robot gigante pilotato dal
dottor goro
regalo però viene aiutato da galligan 15
e jaguar chiede l'aiuto di godzilla per
battere entrambi e anche qui alla fine
c'è poco da dire a parte la famosa scena
in cui godzilla vola in orizzontale
colpendo con un dropkick mag alone
tenuto fermo da jet jaguar variant di
kerr godzilla verso snack a godzilla
sembra il classico inizio di uno dei
tanti vizi classici del film di godzilla
lui e angus si menano come se non ci
fosse un domani
ma colpo di scena il godzilla che stiamo
guardando non è quello vero ma un robot
travestito da lui mac a godzilla aree
triste quindi con l'aiuto di una
divinità che può essere risvegliata
soltanto cantando lo disintegrano in uno
dei film più belli della saga terror
mecca godzilla ovviamente dopo aver
visto il successo di mecca godzilla nel
film precedente
deciderò di riutilizzarlo per cercare
nuovamente di distruggere la terra
questa volta però insieme ad un nuovo
mostro il titano saurus un dinosauro
marino sembra quasi che godzilla venga
battuta è invece no che c'è vi
aspettavate un finale diverso più
piccola particolarità anche qui questo
quindicesimo film conclude la prima era
dei film di godzilla e in italia questo
film è stato chiamato distruggete kong
la terra è in pericolo tralasciando che
sembra il titolo di una vecchia puntata
di dragon ball chi è con cosa avete
visto che chi è com dove kong nel film
the return of godzilla dieci anni dopo
nel 1984
parte la seconda era godzilla con quello
che è praticamente un seguito remake del
primissimo film godzilla attacca al
giappone i militari cercano invano di
abbatterlo viene deviato verso un
vulcano e fatto cadere dentro a posto
così godzilla versus violante questo
film ha una storia con tale
inquietante sottotrame che sarebbe
perfetto come ipotetica sesta stagione
di alias
sappiate solo che decidono di usare le
cellule di godzilla mischiate con quelle
di alcune piante per creare un virus per
abbattere l'eventuale ritorno di
godzilla dite che ce la fanno
no e anzi con questo errore creano un
nuovo mostro violante godzilla lo batte
e se ne va immergendosi nell'oceano
godzilla versus king ed ora sapete cosa
manca in questi film già abbastanza
strani per noi occidentali i viaggi nel
tempo i giapponesi decidono di tornare
indietro nel tempo per fermare godzilla
prima che attacchi tokyo nel primissimo
film ce la fanno
il problema è che nel presente ed ora
sta attaccando giappone ma se godzilla
adesso non esiste più come si fa niente
che vuoi fare si scopre che godzilla non
è mai stato l'unico godzilla infatti se
ne sveglia uno nuovo che affronta di
dora e lo uccide
e se tutto questo ben di dio per voi non
fosse ancora abbastanza dal futuro
inviano nel presente un nuovo chi d'ora
riparato dalla battaglia prima e
trasformato sorpresa sorpresa in un
cyborg e cadi d'ora dopo lo scontro
devastante entrambi finiscono in acqua
senza sapere chi abbia vinto solo
applausi
godzilla versus mostra ma non l'avevamo
già visto beh questo è un seguito di
quello scontro si scopre che quando gli
umani trattano male la natura il cosmo
per bilanciarsi risveglia batra una
specie di versione modificata dimostra
che si incazza come una bestia e inizia
a distruggere tutto quindi viene mandata
mostra per calmare la sorella e godzilla
giustamente dice è che io niente che
c'entro io sto film mi lasciate a mani
vuote quindi arriva pure lui a lottare
che uccideva tra e molta riesce a
scappare
godzilla verso smecca godzilla 2 ott io
mi chiedo cosa succederà in questo film
viene ritrovato un nuovo con dentro un
picco
solo così la no ringraziando il signore
non è lui il padre ovviamente si incazza
e lo rivuole indietro quindi militare in
liberal il nuovo mega godzilla e
incredibilmente riescono a batterlo ma
arriva road han che lo riporta in vita
per permettergli di sconfiggere il mega
così la e di ritornare in mare con il
figlio godzilla verso space godzilla i
militari costruiscono mago era un enorme
robot per tenere a bada godzilla a
quanto pare nello spazio sono finite
delle cellule di godzilla che hanno dato
vita a space godzilla il mostro
cristallizzato che rapisce godzilla
junior dalla sua isola quindi godzilla
padre emo guera si uniscono per
disintegrarlo uccidendolo
ma purtroppo viene distrutto anche ma
guerra godzilla versus the stroia avete
presente la bomba oxygen destroyer che
uccise il primo godzilla nel primissimo
film
a quanto pare per errore con quella
esplosione hanno creato dei mostri nelle
fogne di tokyo oops
purtroppo però godzilla sta per morire
ed essendo stato creato dalle radiazioni
sta per esplodere
quindi in aiuto di tokyo arriva anche il
figlio che ora è il più figo che mai ma
purtroppo vengono abbattuti
entrambi sono i militari ad uccidere des
[ __ ] e a guardare godzilla morire per
davvero
e qui si conclude la seconda era ma nel
1999 inizia la terza con film la cui
trama è molto ma molto più semplice ed
il primo e godzilla 2000 ecco perché
adoro fare questi cazzo di video siamo
riusciti a trovare una cosa che godzilla
ha in comune con fantozzi comunque anche
questo è una specie di remake seguito
c'è godzilla che distrugge il giappone
ma una specie di alieno si fonde con le
cellule del re dei mostri dando vita ad
olga un enorme spaventosa creatura che
però muore quasi subito fine godzilla
versus
guy un sub con un'arma che produce buchi
neri
roba che tutti hanno in casa creano un
portale in cui una creatura preistorica
raggiunge il nostro mondo e ci lascia
delle uova da cui escono delle piccole
creature alate insieme al sangue di
godzilla mannaggia alla miseria se
uniranno insieme per creare mega guy
roux e come al solito viene bruciato dal
suo fiato amico di godzilla il prossimo
film io lo voterei come miglior titolo
di un film della storia del cinema
godzilla mostra è il king di dora
challant monster all out atac godzilla
nuovamente attacca il giappone
scontrandosi prima con paragon poi con
mostra ed infine con chi dona la fine
molto particolare entrano con un
sottomarino nel corpo di godzilla come
tesoro mi si sono ristretti i ragazzi e
gli sparano un missile disintegrando lo
godzilla versus mecca godzilla si di
nuovo e la trama è semplicissima viene
creato un mega così la con dentro le
ossa del primo mozilla ma godzilla è
costretto a ritirarsi è infatti il
prossimo film e tokyo sos cosa
ovviamente questo è il seguito diretto
di godzilla del suo make a godzilla
godzilla si riprende e parte per
distruggere e nuovo tokyo il governo
cerca in fretta e furia di ricostruire
mecca godzilla e insieme a mostra
provano a fermarlo senza riuscirci
godzilla e mega godzilla però finiscono
in mare ma non è ancora finita
godzilla fi dal wars quest'ultimo film e
follia ci sono tutti i mostri mai
apparsi nei film precedenti di roda
nagui rus mostra di dora ed ora c'è pure
quello schifo di merda di mini la poi ci
sono combattimenti di arti marziali
battaglie spaziali alieni che invadono
la terra
mio dio il mio cuore non regge tutta sta
roba e qui si conclude non solo la terza
era dei figli
silla che poi appunto abbiamo visto che
si riprenderà con l'ultimo sheen
godzilla ma abbiamo terminato anche
questo video quindi grazie mille per
aver seguito questo video io mi vado a
fare degli sciacqui con l'aceto perché
non ho più una gola